on the final day of the G20 Summit in
New Delhi heads of state gathered to pay
their respects to Mahatma Gandhi a
leading figure in the fight for India's
independence
U.S President Joe Biden left afterwards
for meetings in Vietnam skipping the
third session
a Leader's Declaration was reached on
Saturday with officials saying
negotiations continued until the last
minute the document stopped short of
criticizing Russia's invasion of Ukraine
something Moscow praised as balanced
yes the Ukrainian crisis is mentioned
but exclusively in the context of the
need to resolve all conflicts that exist
in the world Kiev however said the
document was nothing to be proud of and
Aid agency Oxfam described it as
underwhelming in its response to Urgent
issues such as climate change and
inequality others commended the group's
Spirit of compromise but hoped words
would be followed by concrete actions we
need to see more will and more action
from the greatest emitters because those
who are suffering are suffering
increasingly
heavy rain fell on the Indian Capital as
the summit came to a close many here are
relieved the intense security that's
paralyzed parts of the city is coming to
an end the government was criticized for
covering up scenes of poverty in New
Delhi but analysts say Indian culture
and Indian leadership were highlighted
this weekend there is no doubt in the
mind of
thoughtful Indians people who matter
that India is very much a leader on the
international stage according to Indian
media this year's G20 was a win for
prime minister Narendra Modi and a boost
to His Image as a global Statesman the
leader is capitalizing on the Forum
ahead of next year's general election
his message he has transformed the
nation into a major political player for
both the developing and developed worlds
The Forum ended with Modi passing on the
G20 gavel to the leader of the horse
nation in 2024 Brazilian president Lula
de Silva katrinau altazira New Delhi
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera